oh that doesn't look good no no don't
try and do that oh
gosh oh nice
[Music]
you can't do that get ahead of each
woman
no no no no not on this one you're not
going to do a gta on it
[Music]
the pressure's on there
he nearly had his toes off hey oh whoa
whoa whoa
no
look at his mate head in hands you
shouldn't laugh should you
who's driving this me now
oh gosh look at the devastation
is it his first day he can't have a
license
he's not got the turning circle or he's
not created here
it doesn't look like a street that's
actually adequate for lorries to be
going down of that nature
that's the right thing to wake up to in
it imagine that
morning what's that
oh gosh no is that a convertible is that
the sunroof open
your sunroof glasses have gone pretty
sweet
absolutely school boy error
they don't do many sunrooms these days
do they maybe that's the reason why
all right so we've got um roy and his
old rules
matching the car loving's matching today
oh that doesn't look good no no don't
try and do that
oh gosh
[Music]
you've got to give that man 10 out of 10
for effort he tried his best in there to
stop that
i bet he's ripped his chest off
you can't run in front of a car like
that they're rude
[Music]
are you kidding oh crash
you're not even in a car woman are you
serious no no no
get out of here are you kidding you
can't do
that get out get out of it woman
give
how are you going to stand in the spa
right now gosh how can you be so
bothered about something that's so
ridiculous
so the tackle turns now man in the spot
you know what this is the same as
putting towels
this is the same as putting towels on
sunbeds
to be honest i think if i was the driver
of this car
i'd have probably just said you know
what you want it that bad enjoy yourself
knock yourself out
how ridiculous so we've got somebody in
a car it looks like their car park maybe
somewhere we do a bit fishing maybe i
wonder what maneuver you're going to do
there really
[Music]
oh
what's reverse instead of first maybe
foot jammed on the paddle straight off
look t-shirt's off
just like you've done it before it's now
bother it's not a problem
oh nice
cheeky that's a good but i won't be
buying a lamborghini just to do that
um just purely out of choice of course
or driving on the pavement well
she just overtook a truck on the
pavement
oh wow don't mess with her
the car's rolling put your handbrake on
she left her and break off oh
gosh they're asking for it people are
i experience um
a fair bit of road rage sometimes you
have students who
it's already in them and it's really
strange and i find that with the
teaching that
some of these habits have been
downloaded from
from mum and dad basically you know
through sitting
with them for all those years next to
them it's surprising what the
subconscious picks up
it's i have to sort of bring it down a
lot sometimes and try and
try and remind people that we need to be
kind and courteous to people on the
roads you know
sort of treat others as you want to be
treated and it will make for a much
better
environment on the whole
you